bon est-ce que je peux répéter
bon alors on fait du silence partout
attention sautez s'il vous plaît
moteur ça tourne Yves Montand François
Perrier et Simone Signoret sont à
Orléans un film policier réalisé sous la
direction d'un jeune metteur en scène
Orléanais à l'incornot Alain Corneau ça
vous fait quelque chose de revenir à
Orléans comme metteur en scène
bah oui ça fait quelque chose
ce qu'il y a surtout c'est que ça fait
qu'on on voit les choses différemment
quand on connaît l'impression de
connaître très très bien une ville moi
j'ai vécu vraiment 20 ans ici donc je
connais très bien et puis le fait de
tourner une histoire dedans et
d'inventer des personnages de faire
vivre on fait qu'on découvre de nouveau
la ville le film police python 357
raconte l'histoire d'un policier chargé
d'enquêter sur le meurtre d'une femme au
fil des investigations il découvre que
certains indices pourraient bien se
retourner contre lui un film palpitant
un duel au sommet entre Yves Montand et
François Périer deux monuments du cinéma
français de l'époque moi je les mets
je suis très heureux de travailler avec
deux très grands amis avec qui j'avais
tourné déjà mais Simone Signoret qui je
n'avais jamais tourné
il ne serait-ce que pour cette raison
c'est de ce film est déjà une joie pour
moi
de nombreuses scènes ont été tournées au
cœur d'Orléans au centre-ville et sur
les quais de Loire
avec un couple mythique
ravi de jouer dans ce film
Simone signerait Yves Montand ça ça vous
fait plaisir de retravailler ensemble
pas du tout
non même très agréable mais encore
faut-il qu'il y ait un sujet qui s'y
prête sans quoi ça ne veut rien dire à
notre avis en tout cas on a trouvé si
peu ensemble le film sorti dans les
salles en 1976
est à l'époque un grand succès populaire
il sera récompensé deux fois au César un
an plus tard